bonjour vous allez bien aujourd'hui je
vais vous enseigner en langue des signes
les heures
le système des entendants et des sous et
très différents mais ne vous inquiétez
pas c'est très facile justement un
entendant arrive puis vous avez leur à
vous voulez savoir l'heure de sa l'heure
alors il est 15h30 alors il est 10 15
heures et 30 10 20 30
15h30
les entendants 10 15h30 pour les minutes
c'est lourd
c'est extrêmement simple même facile par
exemple deux heures trois heures 5
heures
7h15
- le cas la demie le matin
midi
l'après midi le soir
minuit
10 15 heures
d'accord je regarde
3h03
a comme ça qu'on fait 3h d'accord 3h30
et demi d'accord et demi après midi de
l'après midi trois heures et demie de la
prime et ti gars quand j'ai compris
c'est bien tu as compris
souvent les personnes utilisent
l'expression souvenez mais les sources
ne sont pas d'accord avec l'association
dont sourd et muet
les personnes sourdes préfère uniquement
le mot sourd et c'est tout par exemple
des personnes sourdes peuvent parler
mais elles font le choix d'utiliser la
voix ou pas elles sont nouveaux par
exemple une famille de parents tour peut
très bien mettre au monde un enfant en
entendant les enfants communiqueront
avec les parents sans difficulté les
sourds et les entendants seront égaux
bonjour et leurs reptiles et k
moi le cas
la demie matin midi
après midi soit minuit au revoir
et